Just one brief announcement.
HKN reviews are going to be
done in class next Monday
so you guys should make sure
you come, give us your feedback,
let us know what you like
and what you don't like.
And, with that, we'll start
talking about protection.
Protection is like
fault-tolerance
and recoverability.
One of these
properties of systems,
or building secure
and protected systems
has implications for the
entire design of the system.
And it's going to be sort of
a set of cross-cutting issues
that is going to affect
the way that, for example,
the networking
protocols are designed
or that the sort of modules that
make up your biggest computer
system are designs.
So it's going to be a
whole set of usually
that we're going to look
at through the course
of this discussion
about protection
that are going to affect
the system at all levels.
In 6.033, we use the work
protection and security
essentially synonymous.
Often times we'll talk about a
secure system or a system that
has security or certain
security goals that we have,
so we're going to use those
words interchangeably.
Security is one
of these topicals
that you guys are familiar
with to some extent already.
You've heard about
various things
on the Internet going on where
people's information has been
stolen on laptops or a
website has been cracked into
or some worm or new
virus, the new I
love you virus is
spreading around
and infecting
people's computers.
So you guys are sort
of familiar with it
on a colloquial sort
of way, I'm sure.
You also are familiar
with many of the tools
that we're going
to talk about, so
the applied versions of
the many of the tools
that we're going to talk about.
You've all used a password to
lock into a computer before
or you've used a
website that using
SSL to encrypt the communication
with some other website.
So you're going to
be familiar with some
of many of the high letter
instances of the tools
that we'll talk through
in this session,
but what we're going to try
to delve down into in 6.033
is how those systems are
actually put together,
what the design
principals are behind
building these secure systems.
As I said, you guys are
presumably very familiar with,
you've heard about
these various kinds
of attacks that are going on.
And one of the things that's
happened in the last few years,
as the Internet has become more
and more commercial and larger
and larger, is that it's meant
that security of computers
has become much, much
more of a problem.
So the growth of the Internet
has spawned additional attacks.
If you go look at a
website, for example,
there are several
security websites
that track recent security
breaches. This is one example.
It's called Security
Focus dot com.
I don't know if
you can see these,
but this is just
a list of things
that have happened in the last
just few days on the Internet.
Somebody is reporting that
web server hacks are up
by a third, some IT
conference was hacked,
Windows says "trusted
Windows" is still coming.
[LAUGHTER] So it
just goes on and on
with these are things that have
happened in the last few days.
There is this huge
number of things.
You may have heard
recently about how
there have been several
large companies recently that
have had big privacy problems
where databases of customer
information have been stolen.
AmeriTrade just had this happen.
The University of
California at Berkeley
had something like several
hundred thousand applications
and graduate
student records were
on a laptop that was stolen.
These are the kinds of things,
the kinds of attacks that
happen in the
world, and these are
the kinds of things
that we're going
to talk about how you mitigate.
The objective,
really, of security,
one simple way to look at
an objective of security
is that we want
to sort of protect
our computer from bad guys.
The definition of bad guy
depends on what you mean.
It could be the 16 year old
kid in his dorm room hacking
into people's computers.
It could be somebody out to
sleep hundreds of thousands
of dollars from a
corporation, but let's assume
that there are some bad
people out there who
want to sort of take
over your computer.
But, at the same time,
the objective of security
is also to allow access
to the good guys.
So one way to make sure that the
bad guys don't get at your data
is simply to turn your
computer off, right?
But that's not
really a good option.
We want the data to be available
to the people who need the data
and have the rights
to access the data.
Often times we can sort
of frame our discussion,
we can say that we're
trying to protect
we have some set of information
that we want to keep private.
So sort of a goal of a
secure system, in some sense,
is providing privacy.
So we have some set of data
that's on our computer system
or that's being transmitted
over the network
that we want to keep
private, we want
to keep other people from
being able to have access
to or tamper with.
And throughout
the sort of notion
of what it means for a
computer system to be secure
is sort of
application dependent.
It depends very much
on what the computer
system we're talking about is.
It may be the case that
in your file system,
you have a set of files that
you want the entire world
to have access to, stuff
that's on your webpage they're
willing to make public.
You don't have any real security
concerns about who can read it.
But, at the same time, you
might have banking data
that you really don't want
people in the outside world
to be able to access.
So you have a set of policies
that define, in your head,
some sort of set of
policies or rules
about what it is
that you would like
users to be able to access.
So almost any system
has some policies
associated with data should
be accessed by other people.
Some notion of
what data they want
to keep private that can
be sort of translated
into this set of policies.
So in 6.033 it's sort of hard
to study in a systematic way
different types of policy.
Policy is something that
we're not going to have,
we could sit around and
have an informal discussion
about different possible
policies that you might want.
But instead, in 6.033,
what we're going to do,
as we've done in much
of the rest of the class
is talk about
mechanisms that we can
use to enforce these different
security policies that someone
might have.
So we're going to
talk about the tools
that we use to protect data.
In thinking about
security and in thinking
about these mechanisms, it's
useful to start off maybe
by thinking about what we mean
by security and protection
in the real world and sort of
compare the mechanisms that we
have in the real world for
protecting data from, say,
mechanisms that we
have on the computer.
From the point of
view of what we
might want to accomplish with
a secure computer system,
some of the goals
and objectives are
similar to what we
have in the real world.
Clearly, we have
this same objective
which is to protect data.
We can say, just like
in the real world,
we have a lock on a door
that protects somebody
from getting access
to something we
don't want them
to have access to.
In the world of computers,
we can encrypt data
in order to make so
somebody who we don't
want to have access to our
data doesn't have access
to that data.
Similarly, there are also, say,
for example, in the real world
a set of laws that regulate who
can access what data and what's
legal and what's not legal.
It's not legal for me
to break into your house
and take something from it.
Similarly, it's not
legal for somebody
to hack into a computer
and steel a bunch of files.
There are also some differences.
The obvious one is one that
has been true of almost all
of our comparisons
between the real world
and, say, normal
engineering disciplines that
involve building bridges and
buildings and computer systems.
And that's this issue
that computer systems
have a very high dtech over dt.
So the computer
systems change quickly.
And that means there is
always both new ways in which
computers systems are
connected to the world,
there are new and
faster computers
that are capable of breaking
encryption algorithms
that maybe we didn't think
could be broken before,
there are new algorithms being
developed both for protecting
data, and there
are new strategies
that people are adopting to
sort of attack computers.
In the recent years we've seen
this thing where people are
doing what they call
phishing, P-H-I-S-H-I-N-G.
Where people are putting up fake
websites that look like real
websites.
So all these emails that
you get from Bank One
or whoever it is saying come
to our website, click on it
and give us your social security
number and your credit card
number, I hope you guys
aren't responding to those.
Those are fake websites
and people are trying
to steal your information.
We see new attacks
emerging over time.
The other kinds of things that
we see that are different,
clearly computer systems are,
attacks in computer systems
can be both very fast
and they can be cheap.
So, unlike in the real
world, in a computer system
you don't have to physically
break into something.
You can do this very quickly
over a computer system.
So you see, for
example, with some
of these worms and viruses,
these things spread literally
across tens of
thousands of computers
in a matter of seconds.
So these are very efficient
and effective attacks
that can take over a
huge number of computers
in a very short period of time.
And that leads to us wanting
to have a different set of sort
of mechanisms for dealing
with these kinds of problems.
And then, finally,
it is also the case
there are some differences
in between laws and computer
systems and in the real world.
In particular, because
the computer systems
change so fast because new
technologies develop so fast,
the legal system tends
to lag significantly
behind the state of
the art and technology.
So the legal system
often doesn't
have regulations or
rules that specifically
govern whether or not
something is OK or is not OK.
And that means
sometimes it's unclear
whether it's legal
to do something.
So, for example, right
now it's not clear
whether it's legal for you
to take your laptop out
in the City of Cambridge,
open it up and try and connect
to somebody's open
wireless network.
Certainly, you can do
that, it's very easy to do,
probably many of
us have done this,
but from a legal
standpoint there
is still some debate as to
whether this is OK or not.
What this suggests,
the fact that laws
are often unclear, ambiguous
or simply unspecified
about a particular
thing is that we're
going to need
additional sort of sets
of, if you really want to
make sure your data is secure,
if you want to enforce
a particular security
policy you're going to
need to rely more on sort
of real mechanisms in the
computer software to do this
rather than on the legal system
to say, for example, protect
you from something that might be
happening in the outside world.
Designing computer
systems is hard.
A secure computer system
is hard, in particular.
And the reason for that
is that security, often
times the things we want
to do in secure systems,
the things we want to enforce
are so-called negative goals.
So what do I mean by that?
An example of a
positive goal is,
for example, I might say
Sam can access pile F.
That, presumably, is something
that is relatively easy
to verify that that's true.
I can log onto my
computer system.
And if I can access
this file F then,
well, great, I can
access the file F.
We know that's true.
And that was easy to check.
Furthermore, if I cannot access
the file and I think that I
should have the
rights to access it,
I'm going to email my system
administrator and say, hey,
I think I should be able to
access this file, why can't I,
will you please give
me access to it?
An example of a negative
goal is that Sam
shouldn't be able to access F.
At first it may seem that
this is just the same problem
as saying, it's just the inverse
of saying Sam cannot access F,
but it seems like it should be
just as easy or hard to verify.
But it turns out that when
you're thinking about computer
systems, this sort of
a problem is very hard
to verify because, while
it may be true that when
I try and open the file
and I log into my machine
and I connect to
some remote machine
and try and access that
file, it may be the case
that the file system denies
me access to that file.
But I may have many other
avenues for obtaining access
to that file.
For example,
suppose I have a key
to the room in which the server
that hosts that file is stored.
I can walk into
that room and may
be able to sit down in front
of the consol on this machine
and obtain super user route
access to that machine.
Or, I may be able to pull the
hard drive off the machine
and put it into my computer
and read files off of it.
Or, I may be able to bribe
my system administrator
and give him a hundred
dollars in exchange
for him letting me have
access to this file.
So there are lots
and lots of ways
in which users can get
unauthorized or unintended
access to files or
other information
in computer systems.
And verifying that
none of those avenues
are available to a
particular user is very hard.
Worse, or similarly,
this is hard
because it's very
unlikely that a user is
going to complain about
having access to some file
that they shouldn't
have access to.
I'm not going to call up my
system administrator and say,
hey, I have access to
this file, I don't think
I should have access to it.
Nobody is going to do that.
So, even though I'm
not a malicious user,
I don't really
have any incentive
to go to my system
administrator and tell them
that there's this
problem with the way
that things are configured
on the computer.
And that extends
also to people who,
in fact, are malicious users.
When somebody breaks
into a computer system,
they don't typically,
usually, send out
an advertisement to everybody
in the world saying, hey,
by the way, I got
access to this file
that I should have access to.
It's possible for them to log
in, read the file, log out,
and nobody would be
any of the wiser.
Many of our security
goals are negative,
and that means building secure
computer systems is hard.
What we're going to do in
6.033, in order to get at this,
get at sort of
building secure systems
in the face of these
negative goals,
is look at a set of
different security functions
that we can use to
protect information
and access to computers in
different sorts of ways.
And we're typically
going to talk about,
throughout this, a client
server sort of a system
where you have some client and
some server that are separated,
typically over the Internet,
that are sort of trying
to exchange information
or obtain information
from each other in a way
such that that information
exchange is protected
and secure and so on.
Suppose we have a client
sending some information out
over the Internet
to some server.
What are the kinds of things
that we want to make sure,
what are the sorts
of security goals
that we might want to
enforce in this environment?
One thing we might want to do
is authenticate the client.
The server might
like to know for sure
that the person who
issued this request
is, in fact, the client.
They'd like to have some way of
knowing that the client issued
this request and that
the request that was sent
is, in fact, what the
client intended to be sent.
For example, that somebody
didn't intercept this message
as it was being transmitted
over the network,
change it a little
bit and then send it
on making it look as though
it came from the client.
There might be different
kinds of attackers that
are sitting in this Internet.
For example, there might be
say an intermediate router
along the path between
the client and the server
where the system administrator
of the router is malicious.
Oftentimes, in the
security literature,
there are these
funny names that are
attached to the different
people in different places.
Oftentimes the client is
called Alice and the server
is called Bob, the person
receiving the request.
And we talk about two
different attackers.
We talk about Eve who
is an eaves dropper who
listens to what's going on and
tries to acquire information
that she's not
authorized to have
and we talk about Lucifer
who is the bad guy who
not only is trying to
overhear information
but may do arbitrarily
bad things.
He's trying to
take over the data
and corrupt it in any
way he possibly can.
One goal is that we
want to prevent, say,
for example, Lucifer from being
able to interfere with packets
coming from Alice to Bob.
We want to make sure
that packets the server
receives actually
originated from Alice
and were the original
request that Alice sent,
so that's authentication.
We also might want to authorize,
at the server, that Alice is,
in fact, allowed to access
the things that she's
trying to access.
If Alice tries to
read a file, we
need some way of understanding
whether Alice is allowed
to access this file or not.
We also need to keep some
information confidential.
We may want it to be
the case that Eve,
who overhears a packet, cannot
tell what the contents of that
packet are.
We might want to be able to
protect the contents of that
thing so that Eve cannot
even see what's going over
the network.
So notice that this
is a little bit
different than authenticating.
Authenticating says
we just want to make
sure the packet, in fact,
came from the client.
But we're not saying
anything about
whether or not
somebody else can see
the contents of that packet.
Keeping confidential
says we want to make sure
that nobody, except for
the intended recipients
can, in fact, see
the contents of this.
There are a couple
other properties
that we want as well.
One thing we might
want is accountability.
We're going to talk about
this a little bit more.
This says we need to assume
that it's always possible
that something could go wrong.
It's always possible
that I might
have bribed my
assistant administrator
and he might have given
me access to the computer.
And, in the end, there
is not much you're going
to be able to do about that.
What you want to do is make
sure that when situations
like that occur that there's
some log of what happened,
you have some way
of understanding
what it was that
happened, why it happened
and how it happened so you
can try and prevent it later.
You want to make sure
you do a counting,
you keep track of
what's been going on.
And, finally, you might
want availability.
This is you might want to
make sure that Lucifer,
who is sitting here between the
client and the server cannot,
for example, send a huge
number of packets at the server
and make it unavailable,
just swamp it with a denial
of service attack.
Availability means that
this system, in fact,
functions and provides
the functionality
that it was intended to
provide to the client.
We are going to spend a while
in 6.033 especially focusing
on these first three techniques.
Essentially, the
next three lectures
are going to be talking
about how we guaranty,
how we authenticate
and authorize users
and how we keep information
confidential and private.
But all of these
goals together there
is a set of technical
techniques that we
can talk about for
trying to provide
each one of these things.
But when you think about
building a secure system,
it's not enough to
simply say we're
going to employ, you know, I
employ authentication to make
sure that Alice is, in fact,
Alice when she talks to Bob.
What you want to do, when
you build a secure system,
is think about
sort of how to, you
want to get your
mindset around building
sort of the general ideas
behind a secure system.
And so, in 6.033, we have
this set of principles
that we advocate called
the safety net approach.
And the idea is the safety
net approach is a way
to help you sort of in
general think about building
a secure system as opposed
to these specific techniques
that we're going to see
how to apply later on.
The safety net
approach advocates
sort of a set of ways of
thinking about your system.
The first one is be paranoid.
This is sort of the
Murphy's Law of security.
It says assume that
anything that can go wrong
will go wrong.
Don't just assume that
because you're authenticating
the communication
between Alice and Bob
that there is no way that
somebody else will pretend
to be Alice.
You should always have
something, a safety net,
some backup to make sure that
your system is really secure.
A good example of being
paranoid and applying
the safety net
approach are things
like suppose your router
has a firewall on it,
suppose your home router
has a firewall that's
supposed to prevent unauthorized
users from being able to access
your computer, does that mean
that you should then turn off
all password protection
on your computer
so that anybody can log in?
No, you're not going to do that.
You're going to
continue to protect
the information on your
computer with the password
because you may have
a laptop and may not
be using it from home.
Or, you may be
worried about somebody
breaking into your computer
from inside of your house,
say, perhaps.
That's an example of sort of
thinking about the safety net
approach.
You have multiple
layers of protection
for your information.
There are some sort
of sub-approaches,
there are some sort
of sub-techniques
that we can talk about in the
context of being prepared.
One of them is accept
feedback from users.
If you were designing
a big computer system
and somebody tells you
that something is secure
or that there is a
problem, be prepared
to accept that feedback, have
a way to accept that feedback
and respond to that feedback.
Don't simply say oh, that's not
a real security problem, that's
not a concern or
don't, for example,
make it so the users don't have
a way to give you information.
Defend in depth.
This is have multiple
security interfaces
like passwords plus a firewall.
And, finally, minimize
what is trusted.
You want to make sure
that the, and this
is sort of a good
example, we've talked
about this as an example
of system design before.
We want to try and keep
things as simple as possible,
but this was really important
in the context of security
because you want to make sure,
for example, that you try
and keep the
protocols that you use
to interact with people
from the outside world as
simple as possible.
The more interfaces
that you have
with the outside world
that users can connect
to your computer over,
the more places you have
where your computer
system is vulnerable.
So you want to try
and minimize, make it
so that your computer system
has as few sort of openings
it can that you have to verify
our securer as possible.
Other examples of the
safety net approach,
you need to consider
the environment.
This just means it's
not enough, you know,
suppose that I have
this connection
here, this connection over the
Internet between Alice and Bob,
I may assume that I'm only
worried about attackers
who are coming in, say, for
example, over the Internet.
But if you're a
server, the server
may have other connections
available to it.
So it may be the case
that this is a server
inside of some
corporate environment
and this server has a dialup
modem connected to it.
Especially, nowadays,
this is less common,
but it used to be the case
that almost all companies had
a way that you could dial in
and get access to a computer
when you didn't have
a wired Internet
connection available to you.
And often times this dial-in
access was a separate place
where people could connect.
So, for example, it didn't
have the same interface
as the sort of main
connection to the Internet.
And that meant that there
was sort of side channel,
in the environment, through
which people could use
to get access to the computer.
Similarly, this means you should
think about all the people who
have access to the computer.
Is it the case maybe that this
is a computer in your office
and the janitor who works
in your office comes
into the office every
night, would he or she
be able to sit down in
front of your computer
and get access to the system
when they shouldn't be able to?
And this may sound paranoid.
It is being paranoid,
but if you really
want to build a
secure computer system
you need to sort of keep
all these things in mind.
Need to plan for iteration.
This is, again, just a good
system design principle,
but it's especially true here.
Assume that there will
be security violations
in your computer
system, assume there
will be security
problems, and plan
to be able to address
those problems
and also have a way to verify
that once you've addressed
those problems the other
parts of your system
that are supposed to be
secure continue to be secure.
And, finally, keep audit trails.
This gets at our goal
of accountability.
This just means keep
track of everything.
All of the authentication
and authorization requests
that you made in your
system, when a user logs in,
keep track of where
they logged into, maybe
even keep track of what they
did so that you can come back,
if it turns out that this
person was unauthorized,
you later discovered that
they were up to no good,
you can come back and understand
what it is that they did.
What all this sort
of discussion,
especially this discussion
about the safety net approach
illustrates or gets at is that
there are lots of these issues
that we're talking about.
So, for example, the janitor
breaking into our computer
or me bribing my
system administrator.
There aren't really computer
system issues, right?
These are human issues.
These are things
that I'm bypassing
any sort of
authentication I might
have in the computer
or any kind of security
that I might have
built into the computer
because, for example, my system
administrator is authorized
to access anything on
the computer he wants to.
And so I have, essentially
from the computer systems
point of view, made it
look like I have rights
to get at anything
I want to if I can
bribe the system administrator.
So this suggests that sort of
in many computer systems humans
are the weak link.
Not only are people bribable
but people make mistakes.
People don't read dialog boxes.
People do things hastily.
People don't pay attention.
The reason that these phishing
attacks work where somebody
pretends to be
Washington Mutual or eBay
and sends you an account
that asks you to log in
and type in your
social security number
is that people don't think.
They just see this
email and say oh, I
guess eBay wants me to give
them my social security number.
OK.
People make mistakes.
And this is the way that many,
many security vulnerabilities
or security problems happen
is through people mistakes.
So we're going to
talk in most of 6.033
about technical solutions
to security problems.
But, when you're actually out
in the world building a system,
you need to be thinking
about the people who
are going to be
using this system
almost as much as
you're thinking
about the sort of security
cryptographic protocols
that you design.
That means, for
example, you should
think about the user
interface in your system.
It does the user
interface to promote sort
of users thinking securely.
The classic example of sort
of a bad user interface
is your web-browser
popping up this dialogue
box every time you access a site
that isn't SSL encrypted saying
this website is not SSL
encrypted, are you sure
you wish to continue?
And, after it has done
this about ten times
and these are sites that
you know and believe
are safe like almost any
site on the Internet,
you just click the dialogue
box that says never
show me this alert again.
There is almost no
useful information
that the system is giving you
by complaining in that way.
Other examples of things
you want to make sure you do
is have good defaults.
In particular, don't
default to a state
where the system is open.
When an error occurs, don't
leave the system in some state
where anybody can have access
to anything that they want to.
Instead, default to a state
where people don't have access
to things so that
you're not exposing
the system to failures.
Don't default to a password
that anybody can guess.
When you create a new
user for your system
don't make the default password
PASSWORD, that's a bad idea.
Make it some random string
that you email to the user
so that they have to
come back and type it in.
Finally, give users
least privilege
needed to do whatever
it is they need to do.
This means don't, by
default, make users
administrators of the system.
If the user doesn't need to be
an administrator of the system,
they shouldn't have
administrative access,
they shouldn't be able to
change anything that they want.
A good example of least
privilege being violated
is many versions of Microsoft
Windows, by default,
make the first user who is
created an administrator user
who has access to everything.
And this is a
problem because now
when somebody breaks
into that users
account they now have access
to everything on the machine,
as opposed to
simply having access
to just that user's files.
In general, what this just means
is keep your systems simple,
keep them understandable,
keep the complexity down.
And that's sort
of the safety net.
There are these two principles
that you want to think about.
One, sort of be paranoid.
Apply this notion of having
a safety net in a computer
system.
And, two, don't just think
about the technical protocols
that you're going to use to
enforce access to the computer
but think about sort of
who is using this system,
think about humans
who have access to it,
and think about how to prevent
those humans from being
able to do stupid things
that break your security
goals for your system.
This was a very sort of
high-level fuzzy discussion
about security.
Now what we're
going to do is we're
going to drill in on
some of these more
specific technical protocols.
And today we're going to look
at a way in which you can think
of most secure systems as
consisting of a set of layers,
and those layers are
basically as follows.
We have, at the top,
some application
which we want to secure.
And then underneath
this application
we can talk about three layers.
So we have some kind
of functionality
that we want to provide, we
have some set of primitives
that we're going to
use to provide that,
and then, at the very bottom,
we have cryptography which
is the set of mathematics
and algorithms
that we're going to use that we
generally, in modern computer
systems, use to make sure that
the computer system is secure.
The application may have its
high-level functions that
correspond to these
things over here,
so we may want to be able
to authenticate users
or we may want to
be able to authorize
that users have
access to something
or we may want to
provide confidentiality.
So we may want to
be able to make sure
that nobody can read information
they don't have access to.
So you're going to have a
set of primitives for doing
these different things.
For authentication, we're going
to need to talk about something
called an access control list.
For authorization, we're
going to talk about primitives
called sign and verify.
And for confidentiality we will
talk about these primitives
called encrypt and decrypt.
And these topics,
this stuff that's
in this middle
set of primitives,
we're going to describe these in
more detail in later lectures.
What I want to do with the
rest of the lecture today
is to talk about this bottom
layer, this cryptography layer.
We have some set of
cryptographic ciphers
and hashes.
And so a cipher
is just something
that takes in, say, a
message that the user
wants to send that is
not protected at all.
And it flips the bytes
in that message around
in order to create something
that is not understandable
unless you have some piece
of information that allows
you to decipher that message.
You can say ciphering
and deciphering
is sort of like
encrypting and decrypting,
words you may be familiar with.
We also talk about hashes.
Hashes we're going to use to
authenticate or to authorize
a particular message to make
sure that a message is --
I'm sorry.
Just for your notes,
I got this backwards.
This should be authenticate
with sign and verify
and we authorize with ACL.
We'll talk about these
things more in a minute,
but it was just confusion over
two words that start with auth.
So we're going to use hashes
to basically authenticate
that a user is, in fact, who
they claimed that they were.
And, again, we'll see in
more detail how this works
over the next couple days.
Early cryptographic systems
relied on this idea, or early
cryptography relied on
this idea that we're
going to try and keep
the protocol that's
used for encoding the
information secret.
A simple example of an
early encryption method
might be something
that many of you
played with when
you were a kid where
you transpose all the letters.
You have some map where you
A maps to C and B maps to F
and so on, some
mapping like that,
and you use that to encrypt it.
And there are
these puzzles where
you get told a
few of the letters
and you try and guess
what the other letters
and decode a message.
That's a simple example
of a kind of encryption
that you might apply.
And that encryption
relies on the fact
that this transform
is essentially secret.
If you know the
transform obviously
you can decrypt the message.
These schemes are often called
closed design crypto schemes.
And the idea is that
because the attacker doesn't
know what scheme was used
to encode the information
it can be very, very hard for
them to go about decoding it.
For example, the
architecture for this
might look like message goes
into some encryption box which
is secured from
the outside world.
It was just hidden
from the outside world.
Nobody else knows what that is.
And this goes over the Internet
to some other decryption
box which then comes out on
the other end as a message.
This is a closed design.
And these designs,
in general, sort of
turn out not to be a very good
idea because the problem is
if somebody does discover
what this function is now
you're in trouble.
Now this whole system
is no longer secure.
And, worse than that, when
you make these things secure,
if you suppose now you're
going to put this system out
in the world with
a hidden protocol
that nobody knows in
the world, now it's
sort of you against
the whole world.
Whereas, if you had told
everybody what the protocol was
to begin with and said
this is the protocol
and there is this little
bit of information
that we keep secret
within the protocol,
the two parties in the
protocol keep secret,
but here's the sort of algorithm
that's in the protocol,
let's let the
entire world verify
whether this protocol is,
in fact, secure or not,
you'd have a much better
chance of developing something
that was secure.
It is sort of accepted
wisdom that these kinds
of closed design systems tend
not to be widely used anymore.
The systems that we are
going to talk about,
for the rest of
this talk today, are
going to be so-called
open design systems.
Of course, there are
many, many systems
that were designed with this
and there are many, many closed
cryptography systems.
And, in some ways, they're
sort of the most natural ones
and the things you'd
think of first.
And they've been very
effective throughout history.
It's just the case that
modern cryptography typically
doesn't rely on it.
Open design systems have
an architecture that
typically looks as follows.
It is pretty similar to
what we showed before.
We have m going into E.
But this time this
protocol E, the world
knows what the algorithm
E is and instead this E
has some piece of secret
information coming into it,
a key, k.
And this key is usually
not known to the world.
And now we go through the
Internet, for example,
and we come out to a
decryption box which
also has a key going into it.
And these keys may or may not
be the same on the two boxes.
And we'll talk
about the difference
between making them the same
or not making them the same.
Now we have this
message that comes out.
Message comes in,
gets encrypted,
goes over the Internet,
goes into the decryption box
and gets decrypted.
If k1 is equal to k2
we say this system
is a shared secret system.
And if k1 is not equal
to k2 we say that this
is a public key system.
In k1 is equal to k2 these
two keys are the same.
And, say, Alice and Bob
on the two ends of this
have exchanged information
about what this key is
before the protocol started.
Alice called up Bob on the
phone or saw Bob in the hallway
and said hey, the key is X.
And they agreed on
this beforehand.
And now that they've agreed
on what this key is they
can exchange information.
In a public key
system, we will see
the design of how one public
key system works in a little bit
more detail, but
typically it's the case
that, for example, the person
who is sending the message
has a private key that
nobody else knows, only they
know, and then there's a
public key that everybody
else in the world knows and is
sort of distributed publicly.
And these two keys are
not equal but there
is some mathematical
operation that you
can apply that, given something
that's been encrypted with k1,
you can later
decrypt it with k2.
And we will look at
one example of one
of those mathematical functions.
The point here is closed design
says the algorithm itself
is unknown to the world.
What shared secret
simply says is
that there is some little bit
of information, a little key,
like a number that
we've exchanged,
but it's not the algorithm,
it's not the protocol,
it's just this one
little bit of, say,
several hundred bits of key
information that we established
beforehand.
It still is the case
that, for example,
this protocol in a shared
secret system is published.
And so people can go
and try and analyze
the security of this thing.
The community can look at what
the math is that is going on.
Let's look at a simple example
of a shared key system.
This is an approach
called a one-time pad.
One-time pad is a
very simple example
of an encryption protocol
that is essentially
cryptographically unbreakable.
That is it may be possible to
break it through other means
but it is sort of provably
not possible to break this
through some sort of
mathematical analysis attack.
One-time pad depends
on the ability
of a source of
truly random bits.
I need some way to generate
a set of bits which
are sort of completely random.
And doing that is
tricky, but let's suppose
that we can do it.
What one-time pad
says, we're going
to call this sequence of bits
k, that's going to be our key,
and this key and the
one-time pad approach
is not going to be short.
This key is going to
be very, very long.
It's going to be as long
as all of the messages
that we possibly want to
send over all of time.
Suppose that Alice and
Bob, the way they generate
this is Alice writes a set
of random bits onto a CD,
writes 650 megabytes of
random bytes onto a CD
and gives that to
Bob and they agree
that this is the key that they
are going to use over time.
We have m and k coming in.
They are being
combined together.
They are being transmitted
over the Internet.
And then, on the
other side, they
are being decoded
also with k where
these two ks are
equal in this case
and we've got m coming out.
This plus operation
here is an XOR.
This plus with a circle is XOR.
If you were to remember what
XOR does, the definition of XOR
is given two bytes, zero,
one, two things that
were XORing together, two bytes
that are either zero or one,
the XOR of two zeros is zero,
the XOR of zero and one is one
and the XOR of two ones is zero.
XOR has this nice property.
This XOR is a
byte-wise operation.
This says the first byte in k
is XORed with the first bid in m
and the second byte in k is
XORed with the second byte in m
and so on.
And the same thing
happens over here.
XOR has the nice property that
m XOR k XOR k is equal to m.
You can verify that
that's true if you
look at a simple example.
What happens is when the stream
m comes in and gets XORed
with k, the encrypted message
that is traveling over here
essentially looks like
a random byte string
because k is a
random byte string.
And this m, no matter
what m is, when
it is XORed with a
random byte string
you're going to get something
that looks like a random byte
string coming out.
And then on this
other side, though,
we also have access to the
same byte string that was used,
and now we can
decrypt the message.
So only if somebody knows
exactly what k is can they
decrypt the message.
This approach is hard
to make work in practice
because it requires the
availability of a large amount
of random data.
One thing that you can do is use
a random number generator that
is seeded with some
number and then
use that random number
generator to begin to generate
the sequence of bytes.
Of course, that
has the problem now
which is somebody can discover
the seed or somebody can guess
which seed you used because the
random number generator used
is not very good.
They may be able to
break your protocol.
But on-time pad is a
nice example of something
which is sort of a
cryptographic protocol that
is known to work pretty well.
What I want to do, just
with the last five minutes,
is talk about one specific
cryptographic protocol which
is called the RSA protocol.
And we probably
won't have time to go
through the details of
how RSA actually works,
but RSA is a public
key protocol.
And let me just quickly
show you what RSA uses
and then we will
skip over DES here.
What RSA does is says
we are going to take
two numbers, p and
q which are prime.
This protocol is in the book.
It is in appendix
one of the chapter
so you don't need to copy
it down word for word
if you don't want to.
If we have p and
1 are primes, we
pick two numbers p
and q which are prime,
and then we generate
some number n
which is equal to p times
q and another number
z which is equal to p minus
one times q minus one.
And then pick another number e
which is relatively prime to z.
So that relatively
prime just means
that e doesn't divide z evenly.
So z is not divisible by e.
And we pick a number d such
that e times d is equal to one,
as long as the product
is  modulo z.
If you take e times d and
you take the modulus with z
the value should be one.
If you pick a set of numbers
that satisfy this property then
we can define the
public key to be e,
n and the private
key to be d, n.
And these numbers have
this magic property.
And then we are going to
be able to, with this,
encrypt any message that
is up to n in length.
So, in general, we are
going to want n and p
and q to be some set
of very large numbers.
They are going to be
hundreds of bytes long.
We are going to
be able to encrypt
any message that
is up to n bytes
long, it is up to size of n.
So we may have to
break the messages up
into chunks that are
size n or smaller.
This has this magic property
now that if we encrypt the data
in the following way,
to encrypt a message
we take m to the power
of e and then take
the whole thing module n.
Now, transmit that message
c across the network.
Now, to decrypt, we take
that encrypted thing
and take it to the power d
and then take the whole thing
modulo n, we get the original
message out at the end.
The mathematics of understanding
why this work turned out
to be fairly subtle
and sophisticated.
There is a brief outline
of it in the paper,
but if you really want
to understand this
it's the kind of thing that
requires an additional course
in cryptography.
We're not going to go into the
details of the mathematics,
but the idea is suppose
we pick p to be 47
and q to be 49,
two prime numbers,
generate n to be 2773,
just the product of those,
z then is 2668.
And now we pick two
numbers e and d.
We pick these numbers just
by using some searching
for these numbers somehow over
the set of all possible numbers
we could have picked.
So we have these
two numbers e and d
which satisfy this property.
That is 2668 is not divisible
by 17, and 17 times 157 modulo
z, modulo 2668 is equal to one.
And you have to trust
me that it true.
Now, suppose we have our
message is equal to 31.
If we compute now C is
equal to this thing, 31
to the 17th modulo
2773, we get 587.
And then, sort of magically at
the end, we reverse this thing
and out pops our message.
This protocol
What we see here is a
public key protocol.
What we say here
is the public key
is equal to this combination
of e and n and the private key
is equal to this
combination of d and n.
Suppose that only Alice
knows the private key
and that Bob knows the
public key and everybody
else in the world, for example,
knows what the public key is.
Now, what we can do
is Alice can encrypt
the message with her private
key which nobody else knows.
And then using the
public key everybody else
can go ahead and
decrypt that message.
And by decrypting
that message they
can be assured that the only
person that could have actually
created this message
to begin with
is somebody who had access
to Alice's private key.
So they can authenticate that
this message came from Alice.
This protocol also
has a nice side effect
which is that it is reversible.
If Bob encrypts a message
using Alice's public key,
Alice can decrypt that
message, and only Alice
can decrypt that message
using her private key.
We will talk more about
these properties next time.
And take care.